bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france bonjour en deux au cas de
contamination détectée mais plus de
tests effectués aussi est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet de la situation aujourd'hui
est ce le début d'une deuxième vague que
nous vivons là inquiet a pour l'instant
mais par contre que ce soit le symptôme
d'une circulation accrue du virus c'est
incontestable effectivement il ya plus
de il ya plus de tests qui sont faits
mais l'augmentation du bancs de test et
et n'est pas corrélée avec
l'augmentation du nombre de personnes
porteuses diagnostiqué c'est à dire
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de porter
diagnostic et qui mit à documentation
tests ça veut dire que le virus circule
effectivement et il convient d'être
extrêmement prudent et de surveiller
vert attendu alors surveiller c'est ce
qui est fait extrêmement prudent on peut
avoir quelques doutes quand on voit
certaines images et rajustement je
rappelle ces chiffres selon la santé
publique france 51% des personnes
positives au cosy de 19 du 20 au 26
juillet ne présentaient pas de symptômes
des cas de contamination qui augmente
surtout chez les jeunes et on se
souvient on a tous en tête ces images de
scènes festives sans aucune
distanciation social au rappel de ces
chiffres quelles conclusions
est-ce que vous en tirez alors la
première des choses c'est heureusement
que ce sont des jeunes et que ce sont
des as symptomatique
heureusement que ce sont des jeunes
parce que il est vrai que les formes
graves même si elle existe dans cette
catégorie d'âge sont beaucoup moins
fréquentes
ça c'est un premier point positif le
deuxième point positif c'est que les
patients asymptomatiques sont beaucoup
moins contaminant que les autres ça ne
veut pas dire qu'ils ne sont pas mais
ils le sont moins que ceux qui sont très
symptomatique
donc on peut l'espérer que pour
l'instant en tout cas on n'assiste pas à
l'explosion qu'on a élu il ya il ya
quelques mois alors nous sommes au coeur
de l'été en pleines vacances après
plusieurs mois compliqués des mois très
stressants
comment faire selon vous pour éviter qu
avec la
entrée et le retour à la maison des
vacances et ne ressurgisse aussi
dangereusement l'épidémie le remède
c'est le masque et le test est ma foi
assez les deux pour l'instant les deux
reviennent et vous y mettez le vous
rajoutez le meilleur masque qui est la
distanciation
c'est à dire quand on est à distance des
autres en contamine personnes donc les
les trois piliers de la dune du tout la
lutte finalement à kiel c'est ce sens là
et le éviter de retomber dans le marasme
qu'on a connu il ya quelques temps avec
1 re confinement généralisez pas ma foi
ça dépend de chacun d'entre nous c'est à
dire du respect dû au simple bon sens
des mesures même si elles sont
contraignantes parce que il faut
accepter une contrainte relativement aux
drm à temps pour éviter une contrainte
majeure au moins de 7 ans aux docteurs
qu'elle regarde ce que vous porter aussi
sur ses quarantaine décidé à destination
des voyageurs qui reviennent des pays
les plus à risque
alors c'est un exemple de certains pays
asiatiques qui alors se sont pas
embarrassés de précaution quentin une
personne débarquent d'un pays supposait
supposés à risques pour le déclarer à
risque mais ma foi si la personne est
isolée chez elle et sous contrainte
policière vous avouerez que c'est pas
tout à fait là
la coutume française mais honnêtement
isolé quelqu'un qui est contagieux c'est
ce qu'on fait dans les hôpitaux depuis
qu'on connaît la contagion c'est à dire
à peu près depuis la renaissance
donc il n'y a rien de très
extraordinaire ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est le faire à une telle échelle mais
autrement effectivement isoler une
personne contagieuse
c'est la norme est ce qu'on a aimé mais
aussi de l'évolution du virus
et des symptômes lorsqu'il y en a alors
pour l'instant on n'a pas constaté de
mutation significative du virus soit
vers une moindre virulence soit vers une
hyper virulence unis une modification
d'ailleurs de son pouvoir de
transmission et dieu sait si les
surveiller ce virus par les virologues
du monde entier donc pour l'instant ce
que l'on craignait c'est effectivement
une mutation qui le fasse évoluer vers
plus de gravité
pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas ça ne
veut pas dire que ça n'existera pas dans
l'avenir mais pour l'instant ça naît ça
n'est pas le cas et on reste sur les les
connaissances qu'on a emmagasinée
pendant les pendant l'épidémie sans trop
de modifications pour l'instant en
dehors de l'importance encore une fois
de latran delà de la quantité on va dire
et de l'importance de la transmission
par les patients des personnes
asymptomatiques qui ne sont pas malades
il faut bien le faut bien le souligner
ce ne sont pas des malades
ce sont juste des porteurs merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions jean-paul
installe je rappelle que vous êtes
infectiologues au chu de grenoble alpes